hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Saturday and this game it also
comes as a suggestion from a subscriber
I've been asked a couple of times to
show a game by the Hungarian chess
master Gazza Marazzi
and I decided to show this one it's a
game against nickel cheering the game is
called Maruti's music sound quality when
the Marazzi mortal game and let's say
something about gaza Marazzi he learned
to play chess when he was about 15 years
old and you all remembered the strong
hastings tournament of 1895 won by Harry
Nelson Pillsbury Pillsbury one at the
head of Emmanuel Lasker and McHale
cheering Lasker talked Gaza into joining
the amateur tournament at Hastings in
1895 and Gaza Morrissey won this
tournament but soon a couple of years
later he will be playing in the top
tournaments held and he will be winning
against all of the top swirled
grandmasters basically Marazzi had a
positive score against every player of
that era except the world champions
he had a negative score against Williams
tiny team analyzed perforce a row kappa
blanka and alexander edition but he did
have a positive score against max Hoover
and he had also positive scores against
players like Frank Marshall McHale sugar
in division offski F in Boogaloo both
and you know some some amazingly strong
players and most of you probably know
about Murat see through his Marazzi bind
let's just show a quick example for in
the Sicilian e4 c5 93 for example g6 the
hyperaccelerated dragon d4c captures
Knight captures and after Bishop g7 now
C for creating this formation opponent
c4 and Ani for creating the Marauder
Marazzi bind and white will at some
point put b3 and f3 to create a powerful
central pawn structure it will somewhat
diminishes attacking chances but it will
severely [ __ ] blacks attacking
chances so if you're a positional player
you might look into the Marazzi bind but
let's get back to this game the game was
played in 1909 t note 2 or 1903 I think
it was 1903 it was a strong tournament
in Vienna and
Mott's is playing against michael
chicken chicken in won this event but
Gaza
managed to defeat him in quite a quite a
spectacular game and for years the three
years after this game Marazzi will
actually be I mean he was supposed to
play a World Championship match against
Emmanuel Lasker in Cuba but you know the
political situation there got to the
match canceled and the Gaza Marazzi here
like many other players I never got to
play their World Championship match
against him I know Lasker due to
politics and you know some wore out
braking situations so let's see the game
efore by murat C we have E 5 by children
and f4 the Kings gambit he captures on
f4 92 f3 g 5 now Bishop to c4 and g4
attacking the knight on f3 and out
Knight to c3
the famous McDonald gambit G characters
on f3 Queen captures on f3 and we have
d6 d4 by white and Bishop to e6
cheering doesn't go for the main line
for example Queen to h4 check because
after g3 you can't capture you get Queen
captures on f7 and the white is
completely winning this for example King
d8 Queen captures on f8 King g7 Queen f5
check and after King d8 now Bishop
checks and I defends you capture the
Queen Bishop captures Queen and F
captures Bishop you wrap a piece and
white is winning this game so after d4
Bishop to e6 by cheering and we have
Knight to d5 now capturing the bishop
was also fine but Gaza has a different
idea gives a plays Knight to d5 c6 and
now Gaza castles he gives up another
piece for a fierce attack C capture Sun
d5 was played eg after Sunday 5 and this
is all with the idea of opening up the
e-file I guess I was preparing rook to
e1 we have Bishop to a5 and now first
Bishop captures on f4 and it's ok Gaza
is down to pieces
but look at all these undeveloped pieces
of black cast so jiggly and should
definitely do something about this a
bishop to g6 my children and now Bishop
to b5 check Knight to d7 and rook 81
checking with DA a one Rock nut with the
f1 rook Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
captures on b6 pressuring the e7 Bishop
as it spins from the rock on e1 and here
we have a critical moment in the game
you know it's how they say it's easy to
attack it's it's not very easy to defend
children here plays King to f8 and now
he definitely allows gather some
beautiful attacking ideas what he should
have played is something like Queen to
b6 and after Queen to b6 white would
probably have to go for something like
c4 and after castles something like
Bishop captures rook captures and c5 and
black is still up a piece but it's not
clear it's definitely an interesting
position and what both players will have
chances here but unfortunately after
Bishop to d6 cheering plate King to f8
and we have rook captures on e7 now
pretty you know standard motive knife
captures and then pinning the night
again rook to e1 the bishop is still
pinning the knight King the g7 you have
to give up the piece or you know you're
gonna lose the Queen Bishop captures on
e7 and Queen to a5 they were trying to
bring the Queen into the game would
attempt on this rook anyone guess I want
a piece back but he's still down a rook
Queen to e2 now we have night to f8 and
Bishop to f6 by murat see a beautiful
move as capturing the bishop results in
Queen to e5 checkmate in one and not
capturing the bishop if you play
something like King to h6
then you get Queen III check King h5 and
Bishop to e2 this is checkmate
so after Bishop to f6 King to g8 was
played Queen to e5 now
threatening to capture the rook and also
then checkmate with Queen g7 you can't
really do anything about this Knight to
d7 is impossible the division is
guarding d7 so h6 was played by cheering
Bishop captures on h8 f6 now trying to
do anything but it's it's too late for
Chi girl in here Queen to e7 now
threatening checkmate on g7 King h8
capturing the bishop but now Queen f6
check King g8 only move and rook to e7
and now black can't defend checkmate on
g7 so yeah this is a the famous game
Marazzi won against the Macau Trigorin
in 1903 Vienna tournament like I said
she Gordon won this event but you know
this this beautiful game was
accomplished by Gaza Marat see the
Hungarian chess master so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
believe this is the first game I've
shown my guess tomorrow see on my
channel I would like to thank Patrick
chop and the Steven Salkin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon